au début je voulais tout premiers
dessins que je faisais c'était vraiment
les deux les dessins de l'attak et que
de l'attaqué des trucs complètement pour
moins gérable
[Musique]
on s'est
tenus tous les deux la main elle a été
blessé j'avais voulu l'aider sans voir
qui a été blessé et je me suis allongé
dans le sens d'un gamin qui était juste
à côté de nous qui était décédé
on a passé les deux heures quasiment
main dans la main c'est tenir le moral
a tenté de se faire vivre
[Musique]
on était quand même assez près cgt
illustrateur médical donc avec un an
quand je sois pour centrer il fallait
qu'elle soit productif et j'en étais
strictement incapable j'ai été assez
vite en arrêt je me suis remis au boulot
et
j'ai vu que je pouvais absolument pas
gérer et imagé fait un arrêt qui était
un peu plus long je voyais la différence
entre ce que j'étais avant est ce que
j'étais maintenant et c'était très très
dur à gérer
[Musique]
j'étais en passe de passer on pense sur
la validité par exemple et
ça dépend de la sécurité sociale
maintenant c'est moi qui ai vu faire
toutes les démarches c'est moi qui ai dû
me battre pour pour tous on a fait un
nombre de courriers complètement
hallucinant pour pouvoir réussir à
obtenir
les papiers des dossiers monter les
dossiers et cetera
[Musique]
et je pense qu'il ya une responsabilité
d'état dans la prise en charge des
victimes on n'est pas responsable de ce
qu'on a fait on n'a pas fait
oh non j'ai envie on n'a pas fait
d'erreurs aussi simplement trouvé là au
mauvais moment au mauvais endroit sur le
chemin de fanatiques à la situation
difficile dans laquelle on est la
situation de trauma dans laquelle on est
on se retrouve dans une situation
administrative de détresse c'est pas la
peine de rajouter du trois mâts ou trop
bas à quoi
c'est un deuil qui est vraiment pas
évident à faire on est bon une et plus
on ne sera jamais plus qu'on a été c'est
une évidence jeu malgré tout je reste
encore en quête de ce que j'étais avant